Recall that we said that a lot of this AI agent will have two parts to it,
a knowledge base and then the rules of inference. We'll come to the rules of
inference a little bit later. First let us look at how can we construct
a knowledge base in the language of logic. So what we are trying to do now is
that an AI agent has some knowledge about the world and it is going to express
it in the scheme of logic. In earlier schemes of knowledge representation,
we discussed how there were objects and relationships between objects. And
any knowledge representation scheme we need to capture both objects and
relationships between those objects. Logic has a particular way of doing it.
So consider an object like a bird. This object may have various arguments.
We'll define something called a predicate,
which is a function that maps object arguments to either true or false. So
let us consider an example. Here we have bluebird as the object and
feathers as the predicate on this object. Let's consider this example. Here,
bluebird is the object and feathers is the predicate on this object.
Feathers is now a function that can map either into true or into false.
Either bluebird has feathers or bluebird doesn't have feathers. In this
particular case, feathers of bluebirds would be true, because bluebirds do have
feathers. Now, just like we had bluebird as the object in the previous example,
here we have animal as the object, the same predicate. Now, of course,
not all animals will have feathers, so this particular predicate may be true or
false, depending on the choice of the animal. In this sentence there are two
predicates, one object, animal still, but there is a predicate feathers and
a predicate bird. And we can capture the relationship between these two
predicates, by saying that if feathers animal is true, then bird animal is
also true. This example has two predicates. Here there's one object,
the animal. But the predicates are feathers and birds. And the sentence is
capturing a relationship between the two predicates. If the animal has feathers,
then the animal is a bird. In logic we call sentences like
this as having an implication. This is an implicative relationship. So in logic,
we'll read this as Feathers(animal) implies Bird(animal). Or
if the animal has feathers, then it implies that the animal is a bird.